et on revient sur cet acte 64 avec
jérôme rodriguez justement l'une des
figures des gilets jaunes et david
libeskind avocat cofondateur du
collectif robe noir et gilet jaune
messieurs bonjour
jérôme bégué je me tourne vers vous on a
entendu votre colère il y à quelques
secondes dans ce reportage certains
parlent même de menaces à l'encontre de
la préfète du préfet de police de paris
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire oh ça me
fait doucement rigoler la bien-pensance
des médias mainstream ou des consultants
divers et variés qui sont là à piquer
des colères et tellement d'amour sont
des monstruosités sur les plateaux sa
part appelé déranger ouais bah écoutez
c'est une menace
un jour ou l'autre ils seront mon regard
en face de leurs yeux je suis pas un
violent je vais pas leur mettre un pain
mais faudrait qu'un jour ils affrontent
le regarde l'ensemble des mutilés qu'ils
affronteront la détresse de l'ensemble
des mutilés la détresse à la fois
physique et psychologique
si c'est une menace eh ben je le
prendrais une menace et je vous le dis
un jour ou l'autre ces gens là sont pas
accompagnés tous les jours de 300 flic
derrière leurs fesses pour les protéger
il faudra qu'ils affrontent le regard de
ce qu'ils ont laissé aujourd'hui dans la
france c'est à dire des gens mutilés
blessés de continuer à écrire l'histoire
de france en lettres de sang fanfare
qu'ils assument mais au moins si la
justice ne leur fera pas assumer il
faudrait qu'ils assument le regard de ce
qu'ils ont détruit la vie en tous les
cas justement et on a vu des images où
les forces de l'ordre nous ont entourés
vous avez été interpellé racontez-nous
qu'est ce qui s'est passé balleux le
schéma classique on jeu
je prends la décision de rentrer à la
maison parce que mon voyant que c'était
pas possible de pouvoir déambuler dans
paris je décide de rentrer donc
forcément je passe par un endroit qui
est interdit donc mais il me court après
ça diront je suis loin dans la rue qui
n'est plus interdite pour me court après
et je décide dès lors de refuser de
montrer ma carte d'identité tout
simplement quand on m'appelle on me dit
mais sur des gaz bonjour contre
l'identité
pourquoi contrairement dit à mon
identité si on sait qui je suis donc je
refuse de montrer mon nom de montrer ma
petite entité parce que je n'ai pas
accès à l'or et rio je n'ai pas accès à
leur carte de police l'aurait rio on le
rappelle un célèbre numéro matricule
donc j'aimerais savoir à qui je
m'adresse parce qu'aujourd'hui
force est de constater que vous avez sur
le terrain des manifestations des
policiers en jogging en survêtement on
se demande ce qu'ils font là on se
demande si son policier dont je suis
désolé j'ai peur d'eux aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas à qui j'ai affaire
donc à moi de savoir si son policier ou
pas et donc je refuse bref fils pas ce
qui se passe on essaye même de négocier
avec moi à me demander si je suis prêt à
quitter les lieux
oui avec plaisir si vous montrez
l'arrêté qui stipule que je suis en
interdiction à l'endroit où je me trouve
bref on finit par arriver qu'un pv alors
ce qui est le plus drôle c'est que sur
le procès verbal et vous avez l'entière
quantité de ce qui doit être inscrit par
rapport à la carte d'identité il n'avait
pas la chrétienté dans la main ils
arrivent à remplir un procès verbal sans
avoir un justificatif d'identité entre
les mains pourquoi faire un contrôle
j'en ai marre des contrôles mon record
c'est 6 en deux heures six contrôles en
2h01 garde à vue 135 euros d'amendé
un oeil poché j'ai toutes les médailles
donc qu'ils me laissent tranquille donc
aujourd'hui pour mettre en prison et
pour mettre en garde à vue ils pourront
mettre ce qu'ils veulent menace je m'en
fous je suis inscrit dans un combat à
défaut de vouloir me coucher tous les
jours ils ne font que renforcer la
motivation et la motivation de beaucoup
d'autres parce que touchera gilet jaune
c'est toucher à l'ensemble des gels et
jaune et je voudrais d'ailleurs remercié
l'ensemble des gilet jaune hier qui ont
su eux n'a c'est la police parce que
fausse alerte la police m'a entouré pour
me protéger
la blague ça serait si la police
aujourd'hui protéger les manifestants et
je voudrais les remercier d'avoir fait
en sorte de pouvoir être libre
maintenant mon cas personnel on va en
faire abstraction il serait intéressant
de voir la globalité de la manifestation
est de parler de faouzi justement david
libeskind hier
trois interpellations plus de 400
verbalisation parmi les trois personnes
interpellées deux ont été relâchées et
une est toujours en garde à vue
vous venez de le rencontrer d'ailleurs
il s'agit de faouzi lellouche on connaît
bien une figure demandé gilet jaune
qu'est ce qu'on lui reproche
alors bon déjà avant je vous rassure
poésie va bien dans le moral ces
conditions de détention ne sont pas
mauvaises et puis bon il passe le
bonjour à tous les jeux tous les gilets
jaunes enfin tous ceux qui nous
expliquent alors qu'est ce qu'on lui
reproche
on lui reproche c'est d'avoir organisé
une manifestation interdite
donc c'est cette fameuse manifestation à
palais royal et ans il reproche d'avoir
participé à un attroupement
en dépit de sommations alors concernant
la première infraction
pour moi les pas caractérisée alors
pourquoi les par acte et à caractériser
justement assez simple les dispositions
du code de sécurité intérieur impose à
la préfecture de notifier à chaque
déclarant donc chaque organisateur
un arrêté préfectoral ce qui n'a pas été
fait faouzi ne l'a pas reçue il fait
partie des co organisateurs de la
manifestation hier et il ne reçoit pas
on ne l'a pas reçue il ne l'a pas reçu d
autres co organisateur ne l'ont pas
reçue il a reçu quand il lui a notifié
s'est arrêté d'interdiction
d'accord il est venu le samedi à 13h à
la manifestation au palais royal
lang a notifié l'arrêter on a disputé
avec
le contact de la police de la
manifestation et il a même en fête
demandé à toutes les personnes qui
étaient présentes de se disperser donc
je ne vois pas en fait
est ce qu'il aurait pu faire plus
sachant qu'il est qu'il était
complètement d'aller dans la légalité
parce que faut savoir qu'en fait
l'arrêté donc comme je l'indiqué il a
été notifié samedi le vendredi qui a
précédé samedi il y aura eu un arrêté
qui n'a pas été notifiée mais ce qui est
assez grave c'est comment la préfecture
peut-elle interdire une manifestation la
veille 1
on peut contester justement cet arrêté
la veille d'une manifestation légalement
des camps cet arrêté est publié
à 14h30 15h30 16h30 qu'est moi comment
on peut contester s'est arrêté alors que
la manifestation commence à 13 heures
c'est impossible on peut pas saisir le
tribunal administratif en urgence et
délais sont extrêmement courts
jérôme regret est comment est ce que
vous prenez justement cette interdiction
de manifestation s'est arrêté tout est
fermé aujourd'hui pour nous empêcher de
manifester
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui faut faire
la différence entre déclarations et
autorisations on n'a pas une
autorisation de manifester on l'a
déclaré à la police à la préfecture
d'essayer d'assurer au maximum la
sécurité à la fois des manifestants des
passants et forcément celle de la police
l'action se rejoint on déclare une
manifestation ne demande pas
l'autorisation est tout simplement donc
abandonné replacer les choses dans leur
contexte
on est sur une liberté fondamentale
française qui est celle de pouvoir
manifester leur seul outil de levier
aujourd'hui pour nous interdire c'est de
mettre en place des arrêtés et je
rejoins mon ami d'avis qui dit comment
voulez vous aujourd'hui avec la justice
actuelle pouvoir mettre en place des
recours et être entendu à 24 heures
d'une manifestation
tout est fait tous les outils de la
république aujourd'hui qui met à mal la
démocratie française sont utilisées à
l'encontre des manifestants
je rappelle qu'on est dans un pays de
droit mère patrie des droits de l'homme
nous avons le droit de manifester je le
réitère et une continuerons à manifester
et s'il le faut on va bientôt déclarer
en face de l'elysée parce qu'on a le
droit de le faire
ainsi veulent mettre en place des choses
pour nous empêcher de le faire à eux de
le faire en bonne et due forme et que
nous on puisse aussi répondre par un
recours juridique
il estime pourtant perry s'est lui dit
jérôme je rappelle que quand même la
jurisprudence de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme autorise les
rassemblements spontanés
donc elle n'impose pas un formaliste un
fort mal ce problème la manifestation et
2e coin où il a dit vous vous l'avez dit
vous-même ou trois interpellations
d'accord on eu 400 personnes amendées
donc ce qui veut dire en fin de compte
qui avait pas de trouble à l'ordre
public avait aucune raison d'intervenir
ou dernière qu'une interdiction en
général elle est liée à un trouble à
l'ordre public présumé c'est ça oui mais
attendez une nuit vous prenez tous les
arrêtés d'interdiction c'est du papier
collé un cv j'y vois la vue
alors il ya plein de vie pire alger
pirates bientôt les jaunes un virus si
bien sûr on pourra plus aller dans la
rue à cause de ça tout est fait pour
nous en empêcher quoi qu'il advienne
nous sommes discriminés on pourrait
plaindre qu'on pourrait porter plainte
pour discrimination en fait il ya tous
les arts et essais du papier collé et en
fait ça concerne que les religions la
colle et gilet jaune qui n'ont pas le
droit de lajemmerais july met l'accent
dans les lieux de pouvoir ou dans le
centre de paris
comment est ce que vous comprenez
justement cette différence entre les
syndicats on voit un des manifestations
là aussi massive place de la concorde la
dernière fois donc pas loin d'un lieu de
pouvoir pas loin de l'elysée en
l'occurrence comment est ce que vous
comprenez finalement que d'un côté on
accepte ces manifestations et puis de
l'autre en ce qui concerne et gilet
jaune et bien finalement et un arrêté
qui les interdit il faut constater
aujourd'hui que les manifestations n'ont
plus de poids il ya 20 ans 30 ans 40 ans
en arrière vous aviez un million de
personnes dans la rue le gouvernement
plié force est de constater
qu'aujourd'hui ça ne sert plus à rien ça
ne veut pas dire qu'elles sont inutiles
à défaut d'être une finalité je pense
que c'est un outil est qu'il faut le
conserver
les manifestations parce que ça nous
permet d'être visible de revendiquer et
surtout nous rencontrer et débattre et
de faire avancer aussi les principales
revendications qu'on peut apporter
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui faut aller
plus loin sur les actions de continuer à
investir différents locaux pour mettre
en avant ce qui ne va pas en france
aussi bien des locaux d' ordre
capitaliste ou syndicats syndicales qui
ne respectent pas aujourd'hui les
demandes de la base de 2 des actions
comme les avocats qui jettent leurs
hommes ou les infirmiers qui jettent
leurs robes ou les lycéens qui
aujourd'hui commence à bloquer aussi
leur lycée ce sont ce genre aujourd'hui
d'actions qui sont impactés impactante
médiatiquement et qui font aussi prendre
conscience à l'ensemble des français qui
a un problème en france parce que les
manifestations aujourd'hui ce sont
simplement des gens qui marchent et qui
gueule alors ça ça ça n'a plus donné
plus d'importance
pour compléter ce que dit jérôme quoi
enfin concernant votre question de toute
façon dès le début du mouvement des
jeunes le gouvernement a été hostile à
ce mouvement
alors elle était aussi parce que c'était
un mouvement qui avaient des
revendications politiques il qui en fait
était composé de tout le peuple de
toutes les parties du peuple français
donc en fait ça continue ce n'est pas
une nouveauté ils sont toujours dans la
même ligne de conduite c'est essayer de
dekra zay de réprimer le mouvement d
vous avez ça continue vous avez 400
personnes hier soit presque cinquante
cinq mille euros damende verbaliser et
verbaliser face au bâtiment des
défenseurs des droits de l'homme
représenté par monsieur jacques toubon
donc aujourd'hui si je peux me permettre
d'être à votre antenne de faire appel à
ce monsieur de constater qu'il ya eu un
grave problème face à cette institution
qui est garante de la défense des droits
parce que vous avez 400 personnes qui
sont fait remonter parce qu'on manifeste
en france aujourd'hui
merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté
notre invitation jérôme vegas je vous le
rappelle figurent des gilets jaunes
d'avis libeskind avocat cofondateur du
collectif rom noir et gilet jaune merci
à tous les deux